[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a chinese youth romance
film called be with you spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
ke neon is a 24 year old cartoonist
facing writer's block she has been told
to create a romantic comic book but she
specializes in the action genre hence
whenever she makes something related to
romance it turns out awful like a girl
who expresses her love by body slamming
a guy through a concrete floor the
editor-in-chief gives kineon's executive
editor ming a deadline before they have
to submit the final version of a romance
comic book if keaneon is unable to
create a good story she will be fired
immediately because of nervousness she
can hardly get her creative senses
flowing ming sighs and explains that the
readers should feel their hearts beat
faster when they read the romantic story
a naive ki neon relates the heartbeat to
heart failure because she has never felt
that way ming hands her a bunch of
romance comics and leaves her to
brainstorm ideas before asking her to
bring them in by 5 pm the next day in
the following scene keeneyon is on a
park bench outside drawing a heart like
ming had asked her to while she is at it
a cute dog walks up to her eyeing her
beef jerky his caller says that his name
is ki bao since their first name's match
kenyon thinks it's her responsibility to
get the dog back safely to its owner she
gives him another piece of beef jerky
and holds his leash to her surprise he
seems to already know where his owner is
he runs quickly as she tries to keep up
and eventually reaches the bridge by the
lake the owner turns out to be a
handsome young man named yan shin he
turns around in a dramatic way as kinion
stares at him finally realizing what the
editor meant by a rapid heartbeat when
yanchin asks for the leash she stupidly
shakes his hand and embarrasses herself
she tries starting a conversation but
the man's answers are curt and
dismissive he offers to buy her snacks
in turn for what the dog ate but kenian
refuses all of a sudden the dog runs off
in a direction making yon shin trip and
fall on top of kenyan when the two are
only a few centimeters apart the dog
jumps over them making them lock lips
that dog is the best wingman of all time
yan shin immediately jumps up while
kenyan remains flat on the ground trying
to understand what just happened she
gets up and bluntly asks him for his
number to contact him later yan xin is
stunned by her openness but before he
can reply keeneon gets a call from the
editor informing her that she made a
mistake and the deadline is in less than
an hour kieneon has no choice but to
rush back to the office but before
leaving she begs yon shin to wait for
her until she returns yanchin is
confused but he decides to wait out of
curiosity about half an hour later he
gets a call from his architectural firm
and has to return home he writes his
number on a sticky note and pastes it on
the bench for kenyan before leaving but
as soon as he turns around the note
flies away keeneyon arrives at the
office and creates a two-page comic book
about her first meeting with yon shen
the editor is impressed by the elements
of the comic like the unexpected kiss
and the cute dog she encourages kenyan
to write more about the male character
because it will surely be a hit but to
write more about him kineon will have to
spend more time with him she suddenly
remembers that she asked him to wait and
rushes back to the lake when she arrives
it is already dark although she had
expected that a handsome man like yon
shin wouldn't wait for her his absence
still disappoints her yan shin on the
other hand goes to his office he is a
hard-working architect who owns a
popular firm his best friend and
co-worker shen is waiting for him in the
office shen is close to yon shin's
family especially his grandfather who
plays the role of matchmaker every
chance he gets the old man wants yon
shin to get married as soon as possible
but the problem is yanshin has never
even had a girlfriend shen reveals that
he was sent to tell yeon shin about a
blind date his grandfather has set up
but yaon shin refuses to go at night
kineon goes to eat out with her friends
one of them is a professor at a
university while the others work in a
firm as they talk some girls drop a
bucket of water on kinion from the floor
above the girls sheepishly come down to
apologize on behalf of their drunk
friend kieneon's professor friend
teaches the same university that the
girls go to hence when the girls talk
about someone who broke their hearts she
immediately knows who they're referring
to it turns out that everyone is in love
with a strict architecture professor he
goes to the university to break hearts
every day even though he only teaches
for a month in session the guy turns out
to be on shin himself he is a university
professor alongside being the ceo of his
firm king wu also reveals that he never
remembers any student or colleague by
their names instead he calls them by
their id numbers unaware that her friend
is talking about yon shin kinion
brainstorms ideas on how to find him at
home she writes a blog post about
everything she knows about him like his
height and his dog's name and asks the
viewers to inform her if they know
someone like him one of the comments
says that they have seen a similar guy
at the university kenyan decides to
check if it is true and goes to the
university the next day the first person
she meets is a girl secretly taking
pictures of someone in the other block
when asked about a handsome man she
instantly understands who keaneon is
looking for it turns out that the girl
takes pictures of yon shin and sells
them to his fangirls for money she has
basically opened a merchandising
business out of his popularity when
kinion reveals she doesn't want his
picture the stalker is confused to avoid
having to explain key neon simply says
that she is the man's girlfriend just
then security guards arrive looking for
the stalker before running away she asks
kenian to take the front seat in the
architectural blocks lecture hall while
she is at it she slips a memory card
into keeneon's bag so that even if she
gets caught her hard work won't be
seized keaneon takes a seat in the said
lecture hall and is surprised when yon
shin walks in as the professor they lock
eyes and kenian waves at him but he
plays it cool and continues taking
attendance she notices a puzzle box on
the podium and finds out that every year
yonshin challenges his students to solve
the puzzle the one who solves it can ask
him for anything they want but yonshin
is sure that none of the freshmen can
solve a puzzle so advanced after the
class the girls take turns trying to
solve it but fail miserably a few
minutes later he walks into the hall to
notice that kenyan has already solved it
surprised he asks her to come to his
office she notices the memory card in
her bag and brings it out but yonshin
seizes it he connects it to his computer
to find out that it has nothing but
pictures of him keaney on swears that
the card isn't hers and her intentions
with him are pure but the comment
doesn't make yon shin feel better he
puts the topic aside and asks her how
she managed to solve the puzzle it turns
out that her father was also an
architect and had boxes like it laying
around the house all the time she used
to play with them as a child hence she
knows how they work she also explains an
elaborate way to solve it which
impresses yon shin as for her reward she
asks to be his teaching assistant so she
can be closer to him yanshin agrees but
claims that to keep her job she needs to
make him remember her name by the end of
the week or she will have to resign from
her post keeneon thinks the task should
be easy but little does she know that
yon shin doesn't even remember his best
friend's name to him it is just a waste
of time but kinion is adamant to win the
challenge later she tells ming about her
progress and writes a few more pages of
the comic in relation to her recent
conversation with yon shin ming loves
the creativity and encourages her to
maintain the post as teaching assistant
seeing that it helps her manifest ideas
on her first day at work kenyon walks
behind yon shin reciting the day's
schedule to him she tries to make him
say her name but he repeatedly calls her
by her id number as they talk on the
stairs the stalker girl clicks their
pictures yanchin notices her and gets
closer to kidney on just to spite her
and give her something to talk about a
while later he catches the stalker girl
red-handed but it is revealed that she
is his cousin gq he seizes her camera
and asks her to apologize to keaney on
for setting her up by planting the
memory card in her bag gqu refuses at
first but agrees when he promises to
return the camera if she does is told in
the following scene yan shin walks into
the lecture hall to find ming under the
podium she shows him a notebook with her
name and even translates the name to
seven year itch so he can engrave it in
his mind yanshin quietly whispers that
they can seven year itch after marriage
and kisses her on the lips that was
confusing but it was sexy just then
keaney on wakes up and realizes it was
only a dream in the next lecture she
decides to bring her dream to life and
hides under the podium but unlike in the
dream yanshin immediately asks her to
come out and sends her to her seat
yanchin doesn't lose hope and
continuously tries to make him remember
her name she even goes as far as to
print her name on a shirt and change his
laptop's wallpaper to her face still he
calls her by made up expressions much to
her annoyance
one day she is informed that yonshin
won't be coming to university for a week
because of some urgency at work in the
firm but he has left her a lot of
assignments to do in his place keaney on
is distressed because she has absolutely
no qualifications for this job and never
should have received it also when yon
shin returns after a week he will surely
have forgotten her name but after
talking to his cousin she finds out that
reputation means a lot to yon shin hence
starting the next day she does her best
as a teaching assistant in his absence
when yon shin finally returns a week
later everyone praises kinion in front
of him from the janitors to the teachers
later the two meet outside in the rain
kenyon hopes to be praised for her
excellent work but he gives her an f for
trying too hard suddenly a passing car
splashes water at them soaking them in
puddle water to help her yanshin brings
kini onto the staff room and lets her
change into dry clothes after both are
changed keeneyon points out that he
already remembers her name but is
refraining from saying it yan-shin
neither denies nor confirms the claim
instead he asks her what her true
intentions are kinion abruptly claims
that she has a crush on him as they talk
she trips on his feet and falls to his
chest at the same time yonshin's
grandfather enters the room he catches
them in the act but cannot believe that
his grandson has a girlfriend the three
sit down to talk and the old man reveals
that he had set up a blind date for yon
shen in a moment of panic yanshin says
that kenian is his girlfriend the old
man doesn't believe it and asks him to
say her name if she really is his
girlfriend kinion also encourages him to
do the same with no way out he tells her
name to his grandfather kenyon adds to
the lie saying that she will always take
care of his grandson after the
grandfather leaves yon shin has no
choice but to accept defeat and allow
kenyan to continue working as his
assistant she is overjoyed that she
finally gets to be with the man of her
dreams and also right about him yan shin
on the other hand is secretly happy
about his new assistant in the end even
a cold and arrogant professor like him
has finally started to fall for someone
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like thank
you for watching